Oh
many of us probably have fond memories
of pillow forts with big no girls
allowed signs or a treehouse labeled
princesses only or a college fraternity
full of secret handshakes and code words
but what you might not know is that
these exclusive clubs are still alive
and well in the professional world don't
get too excited though because to get
into these clubs it's not enough to
think girls are icky you've got to have
some serious social clout or very deep
pockets and sometimes that's still not
enough let's take a look at some of the
most exclusive clubs in the world
we'll start with arguably the least
difficult group to join deep inside
Disneyland in Los Angeles the secretive
club 33 caters to those with heavy
pocketbooks and a tolerance for a long
wait the wait list to join club 33 can
often exceed 12 years and once you've
waited that long you get the privilege
of paying a $25,000 initiation fee and a
further 12 thousand dollars in annual
dues pretty steep so what does a $25,000
ticket buy you for starters
you get access to a private restaurant
the only place in the entire Magic
Kingdom that serves alcohol you'll also
get behind-the-scenes access to all
things Disneyland fast passes valet
parking on a private lot automatic
upgrades at any Disney property reserved
seating at shows a private car on the
Disney Train access to special events
and reservations for friends and family
for those who see the appeal of
Disneyland and its lifestyle the
initiation fee and annual dues may be
worth it but for the not so die-hard
Disney fans it's hard to justify $25,000
on amusement park perks if you're more
interested in rubbing elbows with rich
and famous creative types core maybe
more your style at this swanky Oasis in
New York City you'll have access to a
gym a spa art galleries individualized
service a satellite office amazing food
and drinks and a fleet of rental sports
cars Corps also has its own movie
theater where stars like George Clooney
have hosted screenings of their new
films and guest speakers like Dave
Chappelle make frequent visits big names
from Kenneth Cole to Roger Waters of
Pink Floyd have been known to hang out
at the club and enjoy some of the finest
luxuries New York has to offer then
there's the price tag the initiation fee
is a whopping fifty thousand dollars
with annual dues of fifteen thousand
more per year while core may sound more
exciting than club 33 to most people
whether it's twenty five thousand
dollars more
is another question if the city
lifestyle isn't for you there's the
Hermitage Club nestled in the pristine
mountains of West Dover Vermont the
Hermitage has everything the affluent
outdoor lover could ever need
1,400 acres of ski slopes a year-round
ski lodge with its own five-star hotel
an 18-hole golf course fly-fishing
bowling concerts by big name artists
like Hall & Oates and an 80,000 square
foot Clubhouse to sit back and unwind
from a day on the slopes
if this sounds ideal to you just grab
your checkbook and send over a cool
$75,000 initiation fee and prepare for
an additional sixty five hundred dollars
of annual dues on the plus side the
seventy five thousand does cover a whole
family not just one person so really
it's a bargain okay I get it
enough with these cheap clubs you don't
want to associate with the peasants one
of the very finest groups one can buy
into is the prestigious Yellowstone Club
a 13,000 600 acre private ski and Golf
Club and residential community located
in beautiful Big Sky Montana as of 2009
the minimum fee to join the club was a
staggering two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars with an additional
twenty thousand in annual dues okay so
what that's pocket change not so fast
you also have to own a home in the
vicinity which will set you back
anywhere from two to over twenty million
dollars members of the Yellowstone Club
have included Bill Gates LA Dodgers
owner Frank McCourt former Vice
President Dan Quayle businessman Peter
Chernin
and CEO of NBC Universal Steve Burke if
hanging out on the slopes with some of
the wealthiest people on the planet
sounds like the life for you then the
Yellowstone Club is the only way to go
of course there are some clubs that no
amount of money will get you into one
such Club is the mysterious Bilderberg
Group an annual invite-only three-day
conference of about a hundred and fifty
leaders and notable figures from
industry finance academia and the media
according to the Bilderberg meetings
website the conference is a forum for
informal discussions about mega trends
and major issues facing the world and
hosts some of the most influential North
American and Western Europeans currently
living in order to get into this club
you'd have to hold a prominent position
in a global company or institution of
higher learning or somehow contribute to
the global economy on a large scale
the current steering committee the group
responsible for setting annual topics
and event
includes members from microsoft goldman
sachs deutsche bank TD bank and airbus
the super secretive Bilderberg Group has
inevitably sparked some conspiracy
theory since its inception including the
idea that they intend to establish a
global New World Order but proponents of
the group maintained that it was
instrumental in the formation of the
European Union these are just a sampling
of the many hyper exclusive clubs and
organizations that exist around the
world today if you have the social
status or pockets deep enough to join
one of these groups congratulations you
officially have access to things only a
very tiny portion of society could even
dream of so go ahead and put in a good
word for me if you enjoyed this video
consider subscribing to support the
channel and click the little bell to
join the notification squad you can
watch my previous video by clicking here
or if you're really bored you can binge
watch all my content by clicking here
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next week